.
>> CHEERING YOU ON, LEVAR
BURTON.
CHEERING YOU ON.
>> WE'RE BEHIND YOU.
>> YES.
>>> THIS MORNING WE HIGHLIGHT A
BIG COMPANY'S RESPONSE TO THE
THREAT OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
A RECENT GALLUP POLL FOUND 43%
OF AMERICANS WORRY ABOUT IT A
GREAT DEAL.
THE SAME POLL SHOWS ABOUT 60% OF
AMERICANS THINK THE EFFECTS OF
GLOBAL WARMING HAVE ALREADY
BEGUN.
WITH THAT IN MIND, WE'RE SEEING
MORE EFFORTS TO TRY TO COMBAT
IT, INCLUDING ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
THAT NOW INCLUDES THE
BESTSELLING VEHICLE IN AMERICA,
THE FORD F-150 PICKUP TRUCK.
FORD UNVEILED ITS NEW F-150
LIGHTNING LAST NIGHT, ONE DAY
AFTER PRESIDENT BIDEN CLIMBED
BEHIND THE WHEEL DURING A VISIT
TO THE PRODUCTION PLANT IN
DEARBORN, MICHIGAN.
ERROLL BARNETT ALSO GOT TO TAKE
IT FOR A RIDE.
GOOD MORNING.
>> Reporter: HEY, GOOD MORNING.
LOOK, THERE IS THE REIGNING
CHAMP.
AMERICAN TRUCKS.
THE F-150 IS THE BESTSELLING
PICKUP TRUCK ON THE PLANET, THE
TOP SELLER IN 39 STATES.
CONSIDER THIS, THE $42 BILLION
THE F SERIES BRAND GENERATES IN
REVENUE ANNUALLY IS SECOND ONLY
TO THE iPHONE IN U.S. SALES.
AND NOW JUST LIKE YOUR
SMARTPHONE, FORD HAS BUILT AN
F-150 YOU CAN PLUG IN.
>> NOW WE'RE GOING OVER A GRASSY
MOGULS WHICH CAN TEST THE
APPROACH AND DEPARTURE ANGLES.
>> Reporter: AS A DEVELOPMENT
ENGINEER, IT'S ANTHONY
MAGANOLI'S JOB TO SEE HOW TOUGH
FORD'S NEW ELECTRIC TRUCK REALLY
IS.
THESE ARE PRETTY STEEP.
>> YEAH.
>> Reporter: THE LIGHTNING HAS
TO GO THROUGH ALL THE SAME ROPES
ITS OLDER COUSIN DID.
>> YEP.
IT HAS ALL THE SAME CAPABILITY
AS THE STANDARD F-150.
AND HAS A FEW TRICKS UP ITS
SLEEVE.
>> Reporter: SINCE THE END OF
WORLD WAR II WHEN FORD'S F
SERIES LAUNCHED, ITS WORKHORSE
TRUCKS HAVE BECOME SYNONYMOUS
WITH AMERICAN GRIT.
NOW FORD IS BETTING ON THE
FUTURE THAT THE BESTSELLING
PICKUP IN AMERICA IS READY FOR
THE ELECTRIC REVOLUTION.
>> IT WAS VERY IMPORTANT FOR OUR
CUSTOMER THAT THIS DIDN'T LOOK
LIKE A SCIENCE PROJECT.
IT NEEDED TO LOOK LIKE A TRUCK.
>> Reporter: LINDA ZHANG'S TASK
WAS TO ELECTRIFY THIS ICON AS
THE CHIEF ENGINEER FOR THE F-150
LIGHTNING.
>> HERE WE GO.
>> Reporter: SHE WAS MORE THAN
HAPPY TO TELL US ABOUT THE
TRUCK'S ABILITY TO TOW UP TO
10,000 POUNDS AND BE A BACK UP
GENERATOR FOR YOUR HOME.
LET'S SEE WHAT THIS BABY CAN DO.
HER FAVORITE FEATURE TO SHOW OFF
IS ITS ACCELERATION.
KICK IT.
SHOOTING FROM ZERO TO 60 MILES
PER HOUR IN 4.5 SECONDS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WOW!
>> 563 HORSEPOWER AND 775 POUNDS
OF TORQUE.
THAT SPEAKS FOR ITSELF.
>> Reporter: WHY IS FORD DOING
THIS NOW?
>> I THINK THIS IS AN INDICATION
THAT FORD BELIEVES EVs ARE READY
TO GO MAINSTREAM.
"CAR AND BRING'S" ERIC TINGWALL.
>> THEY ARE MAKING THE MOST
POPULAR CAR IN AMERICA AN
ELECTRIC THINKING THEY CAN TAP
INTO THAT HUGE AUDIENCE, HUGE
CUSTOMER BASE, AND GET THEM
EXCITED ABOUT EVs.
>> Reporter: SELLING EVs IS AN
UPHILL CHALLENGE.
LESS THAN 2% OF CARS SOLD IN THE
U.S. ARE ELECTRIC.
AMERICANS BOUGHT MORE F-SERIES
TRUCKS IN THE FIRST QUARTER OF
THIS YEAR THAN ALL EVs PURCHASED
LAST YEAR.
PLUS, THE SEGMENT IS GETTING
CROWDED.
>> GM'S GOING TO BE COMPETING IN
THIS SPACE, TESLA OBVIOUSLY HAS
THE CYBER TRUCK COMING.
THERE'S A NEW ELECTRIC STARTUP
THAT HAS A COOL LOOKING EV
COMING.
>> Reporter: FORD HOPES THE
LIGHTNING'S PRICE POINT HELPS IT
STAND OUT.
THE BASELINE MODEL WILL GO FOR
$40,000.
NOW IT'S NOT AVAILABLE UNTIL
NEXT SPRING.
YOU CAN RESERVE ONE NOW FOR
$100.
DID I MENTION THE FRUNK?
BECAUSE THERE'S NO INTERNAL
COMBUSTION REGION IN THE TRUNK
IS UP FRONT.
YOU HAVE PLUGS, A SPECIAL
COMPARTMENT WITH A DRAIN.
FORD WANTING TO MAKE THIS
ELECTRIC TRUCK FUNCTIONAL FOR
FOLKS OUT THERE.
>> WOW.
>> THE FRUNK.
OKAY.
THAT'S A NEW WORD.
>> I WANT A FRUNK.
>> I WANT A FRUNK, TOO.
>> HOW LONG CAN THIS THING RUN
ON A CHARGE?
>> THE BASELINE MODEL FOR 230
MILES.
BUT THE UPGRADED VERSION CAN GET
TO 300.
THAT'S COMPARABLE WITH TESLA'S.
IT CAN ALSO CHARGE IN YOUR HOUSE
OVERNIGHT FOR 12 TO 16 HOURS.
OF COURSE, YOU CAN UPGRADE IF
YOU WANT.
FORD DESCRIBES THIS AS HAVING
THE BODY OF A BEAST BUT THE SOUL
OF A SPORTS CAR.
THAT ZERO TO 60 THAT PUSHES US
BACK WAS REALLY SOMETHING ELSE.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY, DID IT
SEEM THAT GOOD GIDDY UP?
FOR SOME REASON WHEN I THINK OF
ELECTRIC CARS -- I KNOW IT'S
FALSE -- I DON'T THINK OF THEM
AS BEING ABLE TO GO AS FAST.
I KNOW THAT'S NOT TRUE.
BUT CERTAINLY NOT IN A TRUCK.
>> THAT'S THE BRANDING PROBLEM
EVs HAVE.
YOU HAVE ALL OF THAT TORQUE
AVAILABLE AS SOON AS YOU HIT THE
PEDAL.
>> YEAH.
>> SO AS SOON AS LINDA ZHANG,
THE ENGINEER, ACCELERATED, YOU
WERE PUSHED BACK INTO THE SEAT.
FORD HOPES THAT THIS CONVINCES
FOLKS WHO WANT TRUCKS TO JUST
TRY IT.
GET IN THE CAR, TEST IT FOR
YOURSELF, SEE WHAT YOU THINK.
>> I CAN'T GET OVER THE NUMBERS
YOU SAID COMPARED TO THE iPHONE
AND THE TRUCK.
I HAD NO IDEA.
>> THE F-150 IS AN AMERICAN
LEGEND.
FORD USING THIS BRAND TO GO
ELECTRIC SAYS SOMETHING.
$40,000 PLUS A FEDERAL REBATE.
THIS IS SOMETHING TO KEEP AN EYE
ON.
>> HOW MANY DID YOU BUY?
YOU HAVE A WIFE --
>> WE'LL SEE.
WE'LL SEE.
I'LL TEST OUT SOME OTHER EVs
FIRST.
>>